seit 500 Jahren gibt es mitten in der
bayerischen Stadt Augsburg die Fuggerei
die älteste Sozialsiedlung der Welt in
den 142 Wohnungen auf zwei Stockwerken
leben heutzutage rund 150 Menschen mit
sehr geringem Einkommen die Miete
beträgt nur 88 Cent pro Jahr ein
winziger Bruchteil dessen was eine
Wohnung normalerweise in Deutschland
kostet die 7 Gassen der Fuggerei sind
wie ein kleines Dorf auf rund 15000
Quadratmeter
also das ist jetzt die Küche und die ist
zwar nicht groß aber
vollkommen reicht für mich als
Einzelperson dort zu leben für meine
Wohnung besonders ist halt eben knapp 60
Quadratmeter was auch eigentlich relativ
großes ich bin froh und ich bin
glücklich jetzt erleben und vor allem
habe ich keine Sorge mir jetzt momentan
keine Geldsorgen mehr
das ist die Fuggerei überhaupt gibt
liegt an Jakob Fugger der
Kaufmann aus Augsburg guide im 16
Jahrhundert als der wohl reichste Mann
seiner Zeit er stiftete
1521 die Fuggerei als Wohnort für
Bedürftige und zwar auf ewig
[Musik]
Alexander erbgraf fugger-babenhausen
gehört in 16 Generation zur Verwaltung
der Stiftung die sich vorwiegend aus
Einnahmen aus der eigenen
Forstwirtschaft finanziert
[Musik]
der Stifter hat in der Stiftungsurkunde
definiert dass
unverschuldet in Not geratene Menschen
aus der Region aus Augsburg hier sich
als Bewohner bewerben können weil die
Liste der Bewerber ist ist leider länger
als als die die Plätze die wir anbieten
können der Grundansatz der hier gelebt
wird ist Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe also dass
die Personen die wir in der Fuggerei
aufnehmen
tatsächlich auch unterstützt werden
irgendwann auch wieder ausziehen zu
können
im Laufe der Jahrhunderte wurde die
Fuggerei vergrößert und modernisiert
auch nach der Zerstörung im Zweiten
Weltkrieg ein kleines Museum zeigt wie
man vor 500 Jahren in der Fuggerei lebte
hier sind jetzt in der Stube ist
eigentlich ein sehr großzügiger Raum für
die damalige Zeit dieser Raum wurde
nicht nur als als Wohnzimmer genutzt
sondern auch als Stube um der Arbeit
nachzukommen hier waren ja auch viel
Handwerker ist
[Musik]
das Schlafzimmer oder die Kammer
der Raum war
unbeheizt und wahrscheinlich hat die
ganze Familie auch in in in diesem
Zimmer gemeinsam geschlafen man sieht an
diesem Bett kann man aus der Schublade
des
erweitern für die Kinder
der katholische Glaube ist ein Muss in
der Fuggerei alle Bewohner sind seit 500
Jahren dazu angehalten täglich drei
Gebiete zu sprechen so wollte sich der
Stifter ewiges Seelenheil sichern
die 23-Jährige hat bereits einen
achtjährigen Sohn und noch keine
Berufsausbildung